Det går ju inte, man måste ju som företagsledare tänka på vart ger min tid mest värde.
Men jag anser ändå att jag blir en bättre bolagsbyggare om jag fortsätter ha en viss kontakt med mina kunder alltid.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har rendesbra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta men jag säger.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Välkommen till Make Sweden Stronger.
Idag har vi med oss Amanda McKee.
Det är ju kanske Sveriges häftigaste efternamn.
Vad kommer McKee ifrån?
Det är faktiskt min amerikanska ex-man.
Han hade ett annat efternamn som jag tyckte var, nej det där kan man inte heta i Sverige.
Så vi grottade i familjehistoriken och hittade att hans gammelmormor hette det.
Så vi tog det.
Ja, vad var, nej då skiter jag i det här namnet.
Vad var hans namn som du inte ville ha?
Det var Stoker och svenskar kunde inte säga det.
De trodde att det var Stoker.
Ah okej okej, jag fattar.
Så han själv är väl också med efter att ha bott i Sverige en stund.
Nej det är lite komplext.
Men bytte han också namn då?
Ja precis, så vi båda bytte till Maki, så vi är de enda som hette det.
Jag gillar det.
Det är ett artistnamn så att säga.
Du vet, det ligger väl Amanda Maki.
Det funkar internationellt.
Kan du ge oss en liten, för folk som inte vet vem du är, kan du ge en liten sån här, en liten snabb intro till Amanda?
Mm, jobbmässigt.
Ja, vi hoppar helt den privata delen känner jag.
Ja exakt, men jag tror både du och jag, vi har inte jättemycket privata delar.
Jag gillar det du säger också, att man tycker om sitt jobb och det är mitt intresse.
Sen så gör man väl vissa saker lite grann vid sidan om, men jag har alltid brunnit för business.
När jag var liten, det bästa jag visste det var att läcka bank, och göra likviditetsbudget där innan jag visste vad det ordet var.
Jag satt liksom och skissade på det.
Så det har alltid varit en passion.
Jävlar rolig åttaåring.
Kom igen nu, spela fotboll.
Jag kom och sa till pappa, pappa kom och ta ett lån här på min bank.
Och satt och skrev upp checkar och grejer.
Men jag hade alltid drömt om att jag ska driva bolag.
Och jobbade mest inom marknadsföring och på Unilever som är ett storbolag.
Tyckte det var jättebra, stannade längre än jag trodde.
Jag tänkte bara att jag skulle ha ett, två år på CV.
Jag vet inte om jag var där fyra och ett halvt år.
Det är ett jättebra bolag, fantastiskt att skypa människor.
Men jag har alltid varit lite entreprenör och rebell och kände att jag behövde få utlopp för det.
Så när chansen och möjligheten kom så hoppade jag på det.
Då blev det första entreprenöriella, unika superfoods.
Därefter drev jag byrå.
Blev du headhunted dit eller var det du som bara upptäckte det någonstans?
När jag var på Junilover så hade vi ett projekt där vi skulle utveckla ett nytt brand.
Och det gick så långsamt att få approval globalt.
För lilla Sverige brydde sig ingen om.
Det tog så lång tid att till slut så sa, vi hade ett bolag som vi samarbetade med, H&R, som även var investerare.
Och de sa, ska vi inte bara köra något själva?
Nu har vi liksom hållit på i ett år bara för att försöka få godkänt dem.
och märkesnamnet.
Och jag höll med.
Så jag fick ju en dröm.
Ett drömmelbjudande.
Både liksom lön, investeringar och bli vd och grundare för bolaget.
Medgrundare, jag hade ett par medgrundare med som jobbade med mig på det.
Jag tycker att jag var lite mesig.
Jag ser upp till alla entreprenörer som liksom börjar helt utan någonting i ryggen.
Och jag skulle säga, jag hade kunnat vara den och gjort det.
Men nu kom den här möjligheten upp.
Så det var lätt och farspänt.
Man behöver inte be om ursäkt för att för att det var bra tid eller liksom.
Ja nej men jag bara tycker såhär.
Ingen som klandrar än för att man fick en lön i några år.
Nej men alla som liksom har varit så modiga och hoppat av helt och bara satsat.
Och så säger de till mig, åh hur har du lyckats?
Ja jag fick faktiskt en drömroll.
Däremot ska jag säga det var så många personer som sa va, nej gör det inte, det kan ju konka, du kan inte hoppa av din marknadschefsroll på Unilever för att driva något litet startup.
Så lite guts krävdes väl ändå.
Och sen vad hände, vad är fortsättningen?
Så jag jobbade med det i ett och ett halvt år och vi hade lite olika syn på driva bolag, det var liksom mycket pengar, mycket investeringar och jag är lite mer bootstrapping person så att strategierna är alajnade inte riktigt skulle man säga.
Det var ganska mycket pengar för att vara ett så litet bolag.
Det var ju fyra gånger mer än vad jag har gjort vinst sammanlagt på gymkompaniet under elva år här.
Vad använder man pengar till när man så tidigt i resan är det att bygga varumärke då?
Ja, men ganska mycket så och jag tycker att fördelen är att man kan göra allting väldigt rätt och bra från början.
Vissa pengar tyckte jag var ett kontor på biblioteksgatan kändes bara som pengar i sjön.
För mig kan jag sitta hemma och jobba istället och spara de pengarna.
Jag ville lägga så mycket pengar som möjligt bara på tillväxt, performance, marketing.
Medan vår investering i brand, den buron som byggde varumärket, det var faktiskt fantastiskt.
Jag kan inte säga riktigt att jag hade gjort det själv idag med mina egna bootstrappade pengar.
Men det var väldigt nice att man hade headspace och det spelade ingen roll.
När vi beställde våra shakers, vi beställde in 30 000 på en gång.
Då fick vi bättre pris per styck och så vidare.
Det hade man inte gjort om man var egenfinansierad.
Nej, jag kör för det.
Det är farligt att ha mycket pengar också.
Jag tänker det själv nu när Mykkaonio, så länge man är tvungen att hela tiden driva lönsamhet, men jag tänker ju månad för månad, och då är det mycket lättare att vara lönsam.
Än om man har för mycket pengar, då är det lätt att använda för mycket pengar också.
Men förutom att man skaffar ett fint kontor, vad är de andra stora, vad ska vi kalla, quote från mig, korkare besluten som man gör, som man kanske inte borde göra om man har så mycket pengar?
Mycket dyra löner, bara många personer egentligen.
Vi var ju typ fem, sex pers, inte riktigt på heltid men från början.
Sedan typ content, varje gång vi skulle skapa content så skulle det liksom vara genom den här byrån som har gjort vår brandidentity och sen så funkar inte MetaAds och det vet ju fler idag men på den tiden var det fem år sedan.
Så när vi ska köpa tio bilder för hundratusen, och jag bara, ja hur vet jag att de kommer att prestera bra på Meta?
Jag fick inte min rojkalkyl att gå ihop där.
Jag tror också att det är sunt att ha lite bootstrapping-beteende i grunden, i alla fall i några år bara, så man har med sig det sen när man är.
Det sätter också en kultur i hela bolaget.
Jag har ju fortfarande, jag ska inte outa men jag gör det ändå, men Jakob på lagret har ju inte köpt byxor på nio år, de är liksom söndrig, det är traser.
Nu köpte han ett nytt par.
Det är inte jag som säger åt honom att han inte får köpa byxor, utan det är han någonstans som säger vi köper inte nya byxor förrän man köper nya byxor.
Det har liksom bara satt sig.
Nej exakt, jag har silvertapad dator och folk säger bara Amanda du kan inte ha den där i mätaren, det kan inte gå så där.
Jag är nästan lite stolt över min silvertapad dator, den funkar ju bra, jag var lite orolig inför den här poddningsspelningen, men jag hoppas att det inte börjar lagga.
Men jag har ingen lust att lägga 25 000 på en dator, de pengarna kan gå bättre till passning någonstans.
Exakt.
Men sen hamnade du på Strict Ace, vad är det för bolag?
Ja, jag hamnade på, alltså startade.
Det var faktiskt då för att jag fick mycket förfrågningar från folk som ville att jag skulle hjälpa med digital marknadsföring.
Och så blev det ett bolag av det, och så blev det en anställd och en anställd till och så.
Och det är, vi hjälper bolag med performance marketing.
Med meta-annonser och content framförallt.
Det är ingenting som jag pushar aktivt nu.
Vi får mycket förfrågningar, bara liksom löpande.
Någon skriver i veckan, jag vet inte hur de har hittat mig.
Men faktiskt mycket, det var bara rekommendationer, word of mouth.
Och jag tyckte det var bättre.
Jag ser många digitala byråer, de gör annonser, in posts och grejer.
Jag tyckte bara, jag är ett bra jobb, så kommer folk.
Folk känner ju varandra i e-handelsbranschen, de pratar med varandra.
Och låter resultaten tala för sig istället.
Så det var en bra väg för oss.
Jag tror att folk skulle bli förvånade om man visste hur mycket det snackas.
Det är så extremt liten värld i e-handelsvärlden.
Så fort någon ska gå in med en ny byrå eller någon ska starta någonting nytt med 3D-påddslag eller någonting så vet man ju 10 personer som har jobbat där eller håller koll.
Det finns ju någon sorts blacklist och shitlist och goodlist i allas medvetanden som snurrar runt på något sätt.
Som är mycket mer viktiga än marknadsföringen så att säga.
Okej men idag ska vi ändå prata lite grann om ett annat bolag som heter Keanu.
Säger jag det rätt?
Yes.
Vad är det för bolag och kan du berätta storyn här?
Så det var några utav Desenio grundarna som startade Keanu för samma år faktiskt som Inika.
Vi lanserade exakt samtidigt så jag har haft bra koll på brandet och skuggat dem som en competitor från början.
Sen så fick de samma investerargrupp som jag, så de jobbade faktiskt mycket ihop.
Och när jag hörde av mig till mina förra investerare flera år efter att jag hade slutat och frågade om de ville sälja Inika till mig, så landade det istället i Keanu.
För de hade flera bolag som var lite luknande.
Och det är ett fint bolag som av många omständigheter inte kommit till sin fulla rätt och fått flyga.
Jag tittade på det och såg framförallt att metaannonseringen, vilket är det som jag kan bäst, är det som inte riktigt har snurrat så bra som jag trodde att det kunde.
Så det var vad jag bettade på när jag köpte det.
Men det är alltså ett hälsobolag som säljer superfoods, matchalattes, superfoodsmixar och milkshakes.
Det känns som att det är ett sånt bolag som ligger i tiden lite.
När ni började för några år sedan, vi är inte riktigt i det spacet men det är klart att jag träffar människor åt det spacet.
Det känns som att för fem, sex år sedan var det kanske fortfarande lite tidigt men det känns som att vi börjar komma in i den trenden.
Det börjar bli lite mer mainstream nu eller vad man ska säga.
Ja precis.
Jag tror faktiskt att det är en grej som jag har inte mig själv eller vår egen insats att tacka men trenderna.
Både Inika och Keano är väldigt otroligt clean label.
Keano framförallt som även är ekologiska, utan sötningsmedel, jättestrikt produktion, tredjeparts testar i varje ingrediens.
Det var lite över kurs för fem år sedan.
En väldigt liten målgrupp som vill ha allt det.
Nu framförallt i år så har det varit mycket på tapeten om vad innehåller proteinpulver egentligen.
Huel hamnade i shitstorm för att de var över gränsvärdena på olika tungmetaller, massa olika brands.
Sötningsmedel har börjat bli lite mer ifrågasättat, ultraprocessat har blivit mer ifrågasättat, jag vet inte om du har sett, men om det bara är jag som är i min bubbla, men det har varit på tv4-nyheterna mycket sånt droppat.
Det tror jag vi har fått lite medvind av.
Berätta vad du, du hade ändå varit på Enika här och gjort några år, och sen så drar du in på marknadsföring som känns väldigt mycket som ditt game.
Jag har lyssnat på det, det känns ju som, det är ditt hem liksom, där mord du bra.
Och sen så ser du Keanu här, men vad var det som gjorde att du ville köpa upp?
Inika först och sen landade Keanu, vad var det du gick igång på?
För du måste ändå byta riktning på något sätt, eller?
Ja, alltså jag ville ha Inika först för att det var mitt love child.
Men det var bland annat en varumärkes konflikt, att det finns ett annat brand som heter Inika, men som säljer andra produkter och flera olika saker.
Och så blev det liksom en budgivning kring Inika till en nivå som inte riktigt medsens.
Så då tittade jag på Keanu istället och såg att, i början så tog det emot och jag bara nej, det var ett emotionellt val att jag ville ta tillbaka Inika för att få ge den till chans.
Men tyckte bara att, nej men, caset med Keanu var för bra för att inte satsa på.
Men varför jag ville köpa ett bolag över huvud taget, egentligen så, alltså, jag tycker det är jättekul med byrå.
Och för att där får jag liksom göra bara marknadsföring och det som jag gillar mest.
Jag älskar inte att vara ansvarig för inköp och bokslut och till deklarationer och allt vad det heter.
Det är mer ett nödvändigt ont som man tar sig igenom liksom.
Så att driva marknadsföring är jättekul, men när man driver upp bolag från nästan ingenting till höga omsättningar och värderingar, så börjar man ju någonstans klida sig själv i huvudet och bara vad hade jag tjänat på det här om jag ägde det istället?
Nu börjar jag klida sig i huvudet.
Jag tänkte ju så hela tiden och tänkte först att jag kanske ska jobba så ett veck och det hela, men då sitter man ändå knät på någon och det är lättare.
Man kan röra sig fram snabbare om man bara äger hela bolaget.
Det är ingen som ska fråga varför har ni gjort en annons som är så här?
Jag tar bara min mobilkamera och spelar inåt och så kör vi.
Kan du berätta lite vad du har gjort sen?
När var du och köpte bolaget?
Vad har du gjort sen dess?
Hur har det gått?
Vad ger oss hela story?
Jag köpte det i februari och då...
Jag förhandlade om det innan det konkurs sattes, men vi kom inte överens vid själva avtalsskrivningen.
Så när bolaget konkurs sattes på fredagen kom vi överens om att vi inte kommer att sajna idag på måndag konkurs sattes det och jag kontaktade konkursförvaltaren direkt och fick det till ett bättre pris än vad det annars.
Och i början så fanns det en del produkter på lager, men inte alls mycket.
Så vi började bara dra igång med marknadsföring.
Jag trodde faktiskt att det skulle gå snabbare, de här produkterna som jag kommer att säljas ut på någon vecka.
Men det var lite segare.
Varje bolag är sitt eget art kan man säga, och man måste lära sig hur man ska hantera just den.
Sen ett par veckor in, då lossnade takk och lov.
Och jag har ju bettat nästan allt jag äger och har på det här.
Får man fråga vad du betalar eller?
Nej, ett alldeles för bra pris.
Okej då.
Men tillräckligt stort för att det är liksom att jag har bettat nästan allt jag har på kontot.
Så det var ju vad som skulle gått till en kontantinsats till ett hus.
Så nu bor jag i min lilla förortslägenhet fortfarande.
Vi fattar.
Vi fattar ett bolag istället.
Men sen när vi började producera nya produkter, vi hade inte så mycket, det var liksom fyra av tolv produkter i lager.
Men vi lyckades snurra det ganska bra.
Vi gjorde nya produkter och då började det verkligen ta fart.
Så vi började från att vi hade ingen omsättning alls i princip till 200-300.000 och sen tre-fyra månader.
En månad efter att vi hade två nya produkter i lager, eller inte nya men producerat några av de gamla, då var vi uppe på miljonen.
I månaden, ja.
Vad omsatte vi kunde ha mest när det rullade, vet du?
Jag försöker kika lite snabbt här, det ska ju inte ligga på.
Nio miljoner tror jag va?
Ja exakt.
20-22 eller 20-23 kanske.
Okej, så för dig var detta ganska mycket ett marknadsföringsbett men allt det där andra, du säger vi, är det vi eller är det du som har hanterat det?
Alltså jag har ju ett team så jag ska inte ta äran från dem.
Nu har vi vuxit och blivit lite fler som roddar det här.
Men i början då var det ju bara jag.
Jag satt ju både med kundtjänst och göra annonser och beställa matchapulver.
Så i början så gjorde jag typ allt.
Hur stort är teamet som ni har idag?
Vi är många som jobbar deltid så att en hel del av dem som jobbar på Vuron jobbar delvis med Keona också.
Och så har vi någon som är lite mer senior inom produktlogistik som jobbar som konsult på Timme.
Så vi är totalt två och en halv FTI lägger vi i Timmar.
Kan du inte ta mig igenom lite hur liksom strategin har sett ut?
Nu när du, du hade ju säkert en tanke när du kom in i i bolaget att, såhär har marknadsföring sett ut.
Det är ju helt fel, såhär borde den sett ut.
Kan du inte berätta lite hur du har styrt upp det och hur tankarna bakom har varit?
Vad är det du har försökt, vilken sträng har du försökt slå an hos kunden och vad vad är syftet liksom?
Först och främst, liksom om vi tittar på kanaler och försäljningssätt.
De fanns överallt.
Det fanns på Amazon, TikTok, det fanns i alla länder, de hade fem olika Shopify-butiker.
De gjorde Google Ads, de gjorde allting.
De hade återförsäljare och fanns hos både proteinbolaget, och Svensk Hälsokost och Rubbet.
Det blir ju otroligt svårt att rodda när man är ett litet team och så här, är det lönsamt att vi skickar de här paketen till Grekland liksom, eller i vår wholesale-kanal med den här tyska leverantören Larsson.
Så att jag skar bort allt, precis allt.
Vi körde bara, alltså ingen återförsäljare, en Shopify, meta-annonser i Sverige.
Så att med det sagt så har vi vuxit väldigt bra.
Förut så var det ju både wholesale och 38 länder som stod för omsättningen, och det var väldigt sprit.
Det var faktiskt ner omsättning utanför Sverige, än i Sverige.
Jag tror det är därför man inte heller har sett så mycket om Keon i Sverige.
Men jag tycker att det är väldigt nice för att jag kunde se att det finns väldigt bra traction och proof of concept internationellt.
Så när vi väl börjar, nu har vi precis faktiskt börjat rulla ut.
Förut har vi alltid haft för lite produkter, det är det som har hållit oss tillbaka.
Vi sålde slut snabbare än vi producerade nya, för vi sålde mer än vad jag faktiskt hade trott att vi skulle.
Men nu har vi precis slagit på Danmark, Nederländerna och Tyskland, bara för några dagar sedan.
Och vi ligger på Roa, Sven.
Det är bara direkt.
Jag har faktiskt aldrig sett det förut.
Det är fördelen när man har jobbat på byråsidan.
Så jag har varit med om flera internationaliseringar.
Det går ju trögt, man får liksom jobba sig uppe bit för bit.
Men det är en fördel också av att köpa ett bolag som som har funnits ett tag.
Det finns ett heritage, det finns lite brand awareness i de här länderna.
Även om jag tror att många har glömt bort det, för de har ju legat helt av radan och inte kört någon aktiv marknadsföring på typ ett och ett halvt år.
Men lite befintliga kunder trillar in.
Hur sätter du upp hur de marknadsföringarna sett ut?
Vad är det du har fokuserat på?
Så vi kör ju bara meta-annonser nu, men vi börjar och jag gillar att hålla det så, för då behöver jag inte sitta med en avancerad attributionsverktyg.
Jag tittar bara på hur mycket jag spenderar till meta, hur mycket säljer vi, punkt.
Sen så liksom email och marketing, vi postar lite organiskt på TikTok och så vidare.
Men med annonser så vi testade oss fram lite och tacksamt nog så var det ganska mycket så här.
Alltså ibland måste man ha massa UGC-kreatörer som pratar om och berättar om brandet och jag har några sådana annonser där jag själv pratar utifrån ett användarperspektiv av produkterna som har gått jättebra.
Men också bara bilder som är väldigt tilltalande ingredienser med en stark koppe på.
Vi jobbade mycket med att försöka hitta kärnan, vad är uspen i varumärket och vart vi är unika.
Och det är ju mera av det här hur clean labeled faktiskt är.
Och ekologiskt och utan sätningsmedel.
Utan sätningsmedel är faktiskt en jättestark usp.
Jag vågar inte säga lite dit, jag vet inte var du står i frågan, för det är en heliko.
Nej jag har ingen, jag har inga...
Du har ingen stark åsikt åt det ena eller andra.
Nej men alltså det är ju folk som sågar oss i kommentarsflödet ibland, och bara det är inget fel med sätningsmedel.
Så vi är väldigt försiktiga med att inte säga att det är något fel med det, vi säger bara att det är utan sätningsmedel.
Men bara att vi berättar att vår produkt inte har sätningsmedel verkar provocera många.
Framförallt folk som på något sätt jobbar med proteinpulversbolag.
Jag kollar upp dem ibland.
Men inte det positivt att skapa en vi-och-dom-känsla, spelar det någon roll egentligen?
Nej, jag tycker det är bra.
Jag sitter ju själv och svarar på alla kommentarer som haglar in.
Och vi får en hel del tråkiga kommentarer, men det är också van vid att alla bolag får, ibland när jag har kunder.
Jag fattar inte det, är det det folk går igång på då?
Ni har inget sötningsmedel, vilka jävla assholes ni är.
Jag har alltid så svårt för att tänka mig in i människor som kommenterar negativt.
Det ligger inte riktigt för mig att bry mig på det sättet.
Men Meta gillar ju engagement, så vi tackar och tar emot oavsett vad det är.
Det är ju hur man svarar på kommentarerna som spelar roll, och vad man gör med det.
Man ska absolut inte radera dem.
För då tror Meta att du är ett bolag som försöker tysta dina kunder, och du har någonting att dölja.
Så jag har kunder som brukar säga att vi måste ta bort den här annonsen, för att kolla vad vi har fått för kommentarer nu.
Och det är väldigt skönt att nu när jag har bolaget själv, och jag låter varje kommentar ligga kvar, folk får stå för det de själva säger, och så får vi stå för hur vi svarar.
Men hälsa är ju väldigt, liksom de som är otroligt hälsainteresserade.
Vi är ju som olika religioner nästan, där de ska bärsa varandra fram och tillbaka, och det är lite kul att titta ibland, det jag gillar mest är när våra kunder kliver in, eller någon som kanske inte ens är vår kund, och börjar liksom argumentera mot dem.
Och så sitter man bara där och tittar på, har lämnat över mikrofonen och medan Smeta räknar engagement.
Så det är på ett sätt positivt.
Men det är ju allting ifrån att, varför har ni den där sortens protein och inte den här?
Det där är min sann inte kompletta minussyraprofil.
Jo det är det lilla gubben, du blandar ihop det med att vara fullvärdig.
Så svarar jag inte riktigt.
Är du aldrig sugen på att svara så?
Det finns ju en viss charm i företag som inte tar sig själva så seriöst.
Nu förstår jag att ni kanske måste göra det, för att det är ett clean label och då på något sätt kräver det ibland att man är lite mer seriös.
Nej jag är nog inte jätteseriös, jag är ganska personlig i svaren.
Om någon skriver, det här var det värsta, bla, bla, bla, det här är bara reklam, ni försöker sälja.
Ja, på Meta finns det reklam, du kan betala ifall du vill ha utan, typ så, eller jag skriver ofta, när folk skriver, det är ingen följ på sätningsmedel och bla, bla, bla.
Ja men det finns jättemånga alternativ på marknaden med sätningsmedel, så då tycker jag du ska köpa dem hjärta, hjärta, skriver jag.
Och Volk har skrivit flera stycken, någon skrev såhär, ni förtjänar en medalj för hur ni svarar på era kommentarer.
Det var lite skönt kvitt och jag tänkte ibland, jag undrar vad andra tänker om hur jag svarar, jag svarar ju bara ärligt hur jag själv vill.
Jag vill inte triga nån hets eller fastna i någon argumentation, men många kommentarer bara förstår inte vad de vill uppnå.
Vi pratade här lite innan, då snackade vi om brandingfluff, kundservice och hur man syns och hur man upplevs av kunden är ju på något sätt riktig branding, men kan vi inte bara beröra det ämnet lite?
På Junilever, när jag var där, då var det ju stenhårda, brand books och exakt det där ordet använde vi och inte det här och så.
Och jag tror att många start-ups, framförallt om man har jobbat med marknadsföring på ett större bolag, har färgats lite av att branding är en brand book med vår tone of voice, våra fonter och våra loggar och det är viktigt att allt det ser ut.
Så nu upplever jag inte att så många av e-handlare och framförallt inte de e-handlare som går bra är jättehårda på det.
Men jag har jobbat med bolag och kunder som har varit lite mer åt det hållet.
Nej men branding är att se ut på ett konsekvent sätt.
Och jag tycker att branding är lite fluffigt.
Det jag framförallt har väldigt svårt för är att lägga massa pengar på saker som inte ger några resultat.
Det måste man ju våga göra så småningom.
Men jag har tänkt lite på vad tycker jag inte att branding spelar någon roll alls.
Men jag tror jag landat i att det är ju vad vi gör eller vilken relation som folk har till oss som bolag.
När vi först lanserade Inika och när vi gjorde någon post på Instagram, det var knappt någon som likar.
De som likar var liksom våra familj och vänner.
Jag satt och frågade mig själv, ärligt talat, why should anyone give a crap?
Varför ska någon likea den här eller kommentera?
Om det bara är en fin bild på en härlig tjej.
Jag insåg att eftersom det är våra vänner och familj som kommenterar, det är för att de har en relation och de vill oss väl och de vill att det ska gå bra.
Det har jag tagit med min i Keano att försöka tänka, hur får jag folk att give a crap?
Varför ska de bry sig?
Varför ska de vilja steppa oss eller peppa oss?
Så att vi bygger en identitet som de vill vara kompis med och att vi faktiskt på riktigt är kompis med våra kunder.
Och utöver det, alltså branding, hur vi hanterar våra kunder, hur vi svarar på deras frågor, att vi är ärliga, öppna, närvarande och ett bolag som de verkligen kan lita på när det kommer till deras hälsa.
Och så har vi såklart, då som vi har landat i, att när vi pratar om hur rena våra produkter är, och hur naturliga och ekologiska, det är vissa triggers, men det är i sig inte riktigt branding, utan det är liksom vilken känsla får jag kring det här varumärket, vilken relation har jag till varumärket.
Hur bygger ni denna?
Och vilken relation ska de ha?
Så jag vet inte hur vi ska kunna hålla det här, men jag försöker att reagera väldigt nära med kunden, det är därför jag själv sitter fortfarande och svarar på alla Facebook-kommuniteter för att jag vill förstå vad de tänker kring oss och då kan jag lika gärna svara när jag sitter där.
Och att connecta med dem och inkludera dem i vad vi bygger för bolag och vara väldigt transparenta.
Vi var till exempel öppna med att säga att vi var nära att gå i konkurs, det skickade vi ut ett mail om så att kunderna visste.
Vi frågade dem om vilka produkter vill ni att vi ska lansera härnäst.
Vi frågade dem om att dela sina favoritrecept och hur du använder produkterna.
Jag personligen sitter och chattar, jag har en handfull kunder som nästan blivit kompisar, skickar Bödelse Dags paket till, vi har en kund, hon har beställt 200 burkar senaste åren.
Hon har stenderat 35 000 på Keano.
Och flera liknande kunder.
Vi skickar ut julklappar till våra bästa kunder och vi sitter och chattar med dem om hur de använder våra produkter, vad de har för olika hälsoproblem eller effekter.
En kille sitter och pratar med, han berättar om hur hans pappa gick bort och han började använda Keanos produkter och börja må bättre och kunna ta sin hälsa mer på allvar.
Folk gillar att öppna upp och chatta men vi har en äldre målgrupp som inte kommer att reshare this post och de är inte aktiva på det sättet.
När jag skriver märker jag att vi skriver och berättar om vår egen story.
Jag försöker vara ganska personlig och berätta vad som händer ibland bakom kulisserna.
Så vi bygger en relation med dem och de ska förstå att vi är inget stor bolag som vill sitta och kröma ut varje krona för dem.
Utan vi försöker bara göra bra hälsoprodukter som de ska gilla.
Men jag brukar skriva ganska ofta i våra e-mail, att tack så jättemycket för varje kommentar och allt som ni gör.
När ni ger dina kommentarer på Instagram och så vidare så betyder det jättemycket för oss.
Då märker vi att det blir mer av det.
När vi skriver och chatta mer om oss och kanske säger att tack så jättemycket och de brukar skriva till mig om det finns någonting jag kan göra för att hjälpa till.
Ja vet du, om du vill droppa någon nice kommentar här och där så är det jättekul.
Och då ser jag det namnet sen dyka upp.
Jag köper det.
Man blir ju en liten...
Sen kan jag säga att det är lite farligt.
Jag har inte haft kundtjänstelefoner nu på fyra år kanske, men det är ju fortfarande folk som har mitt nummer, mitt privata nummer, som ringer och så här tja jag skulle vilja göra det här och köpa in detta och detta och det är så här fan.
Det är lördag, sluta ring nu.
Lyckas det stänga av det där?
Det kanske är för tidigt, man behöver kanske inte.
Som tur är så har de inte mitt nummer men, och det är inte jättemånga, det är typ så här, när jag hade kundtjänsten själv första månaden var det bara som jag satt med det själv, sen så började jag fasa in det på en annan anställd och en till anställd som är involverad.
Men nu lupar ju de in mig med när det är någon stor fråga och ibland så hoppar jag in bara för att jag vill, för att jag vill exponera mig för det.
Och så har jag liksom ett gäng handfull kunder som har blivit som kompisar som vill chatta och dela saker och att det inte är för besvärande.
Och jag ser det också precis som du säger, det går ju inte, man måste ju som företagsledare tänka på så här vart ger min tid mest värde.
Men jag anser ändå att jag blir en bättre bolagsbyggare om jag fortsätter ha en viss kontakt med mina kunder alltid.
Ja, det tror jag absolut på.
Hur tänker du att du ska bygga den, vad är liksom feelingen med bolaget, vad är det ni hjälper folk med, vilka är er grupp och vad, du sa att ni har en liten äldre målgrupp, menar du att ni har en liten äldre målgrupp som en liten del eller är det era stora målgrupper, är det ni märker att ni triggas oss eller vad?
Vad är tanken kring tillväxten här, vad kommer den ifrån?
Först då, målgruppen är, många brands tror att de har en mycket äldre målgrupp än de har, men om man går in och grottar i det och tittar så blir många förvånade och ser att, aha, det var visst inte.
Man tror att man säljer till 25-30-åringar, men vi säljer till snarare 45-
och 60-åringar.
Vi tror att vi absolut kan växa mer med en yngre målgrupp också, men det här är ju en bra och tacksam målgrupp på många sätt.
Vad målet med bolaget eller brandet är, frågar du?
Är detta din stora återkomst efter Inika för att visa att bootstrapping funkar?
Är det ett litet, titta jag hade rätt, är det en sån resa eller är det nu ska jag bygga ett stort jävla bolag?
Eller är det en tredje variant?
Du måste inte välja på de två.
Nej men jag skulle väl säga lite blandning.
Jag känner nog att jag hade redan, först och främst, det funkar att driva bolag på flera olika sätt och jag hade väl velat få utlopp för att mitt sätt också funkar, men det kände jag redan att jag hade gjort i de casen jag haft genom byrån.
Jag vet att jobba såhär, det funkar för mig.
Och rätt sätt för mig kanske inte rätt sätt för någon annan.
Sen så för mig, jag brinner väldigt mycket för att få jobba med de människorna jag vill, på de tiderna jag vill, vart jag vill när jag vill, på ett sätt som jag kan stå för.
Jag tyckte att det kändes lite jobbigt ibland när man är på ett stor bolag, där man kapar några av de bästa, dyraste råvarorna och då ska man försöka få det att verka som att den här produkten är minst sann lika bra ändå.
Om man liksom ska krama ut varje vinstkrona ur människor.
Jag är lite ideologisk, jag är lite marxistisk om du har alldeles för hög vinst, då har du lurat folk på annat sätt.
Sen ska jag absolut effektivisera mina inköp, men jag vill att folk ska få mycket hälsa för pengarna.
Och att jobba med hälsa är väldigt viktigt för mig, för jag tycker att marknadsföring, framförallt med Meta och Google som verktyg, jag har mer data på dig än du har om dig själv.
Jag vet exakt vilket budskap som kommer få dig att köpa den här produkten i vilken tid på dygnet.
Och det är lite läskigt och jag tycker det känns lite oetiskt.
Och då man ska få folk att köpa mera glass till exempel, då känns det inte rätt i magen för mig.
Medans, om jag säljer produkter, alltså vem är jag att bestämma att folk borde ha vårt proteinpulver, men jag känner att världen har i alla fall inte blivit en sämre plats om de konsumerar det istället för något annat.
För att jag tror att det genuint gör, bygger hälsosammare lättare vanor.
Jag är ingen filantrop direkt, nu låter det visst om det.
Jag gillar ju siffror och tjänar pengar också.
Och att bolaget ska växa och bli stort.
Men jag gör det inte för något som jag inte själv är djupt passionerad över och tycker känns rätt.
Men du har ändå fått ganska snabb tillväxt i märket här.
Får man ändå ge dig på, det blir februari, det är fan tio månader.
Ser du fortfarande samma tillväxtkurva, eller har den stannat av lite grann?
Ja det var ju förfärliga veckor här precis innan jul.
Så i november hade vi en och en halv miljon, och jag bara så här, vi kommer absolut dippa lite i december, men inte fullt så mycket som vi gjorde.
Nu kommer vi att landa på nästan en miljon i december.
Men tittar vi bara på siffrorna de senaste dagarna så pekar det på att i januari vi kommer säkert att landa två miljoner.
Då skulle vi snurra på 16 miljoner per år om vi bara höll den omsättningen.
Men precis innan jul, folk var inte i rätt mode.
Jag har jobbat med flera olika brands där man har väldigt säsongsbaserat och tyckt att man kan inte padla mot strömmen.
Det går inte.
Jag har aldrig drivit den här typen av produktkategori förut under en decembermånad.
Så jag visste inte vad jag skulle förvänta mig.
Men jag tyckte att det var lägre än vad vi hade förtjänat.
Jag satt och gjorde annons efter annons.
Men till slut så flög det och slappte igen.
Först trodde jag att det var någonting galet som hade hänt.
Nu har hela vårt metakonto helt tappat.
Vem målgruppen är?
Det låg på hälften av den dagliga omsättningen som vi brukade på en riktigt bra dag, eller kanske 30 procent lägre.
Men det varade bara två veckor.
Jag vet att du inte tänker att det är som ett julmärke, men det var ändå ganska logiskt att man skulle kunna ge.
Om ni tar fram ett jävligt schysst paket som är inslaget och färdigt, och investerar i din hälsa, här mår bra.
Det är väl ändå en present som, eller är jag förskadad för att jobba i träningsbranschen i, vad fan blir det, 20 år eller nåt sånt?
Nej, jag tror att det kan gå, och vi hade typ såhär, ja men vårt hot latte-bundel med tre olika varma lattes som faktiskt har juliga kryddiga smaker i sig, det råkar de bara ha med ingefära och kanel och sådär.
Så att vi pushade dem mer och det räddade upp mycket.
Sen så hade jag ju velat typ såhär fixa någon presentpåse så att man kunde verkligen paketera det som en present.
Vi hade presentkort på sajten men av erfarenhet så vet jag att det brukar inte gå bra.
Det brukar inte vara någon kioskvältare.
Vi la bara upp den men satsade inte så mycket på det.
Men liksom i månad tidsbrist och att typ, okej, det är typ två tre veckor som folk julklappschoppar.
Ska vi lägga så mycket tid och effort på det när januari är runt hörnet, där det är missannolikt att det kommer gå boom.
Så att jag satte mitt team att börja göra nyårslöfte, annonser och överlag, vi försöker göra generella annonser som funkar och är evergreen.
Inte så här för om vi nämner nyårslöfte i annonsen, då kommer vi typ inte kunna ha den rullande längre i februari.
Och det är jäkligt surt om den har börjat få snurra och bli vår bästa annons.
Så att då skriver vi istället typ dina nya hälsovanor så att den kan leva längre.
Och göra några enstaka kanske med nyårslöfte i annonsen.
Är det okej om jag hoppar bort från kan jag nog lite och bara passa på och ta några tips från det här kring alla de här jävla inställningarna som man ska göra i alla konton och sånt där.
Det fattar jag precis noll om.
Så jag vet inte ens hur jag ska fråga om sånt.
Men kan vi snacka lite content i alla fall?
Finns det någonting du kan säga till e-handlare generellt vad vi gör dåligt och vad vi borde göra betydligt bättre?
Först en sak som jag tänkte på när jag lyssnade på din podd och dina LinkedIn-posts.
Så säger du att det är helt oförutsättbart vilka som går bra och inte, eller hur?
Det vet jag inte, det har jag säkert sagt i något tillfälle.
Ja, det sa typ såhär, vad är det som går bra?
Jaha, LinkedIn-delägg, ja absolut.
Ja, men så är det ju lite grann.
Man kan inte riktigt säga varför.
Så det ska man ha med sig lite, att det är ganska otippat.
Och också att ha en väldigt kreativ bredd.
Testa allt möjligt.
Gör inte bara en typ av annonser.
Det blir väldigt lätt att när man har hittat något som funkar, då tänker man, nu gör vi en till sån.
Nu behöver NUGC-kreatör till att göra en med den här vinkeln.
Det brukar inte alltid funka, kan funka ibland, så det är absolut värt att testa att försöka replikera en success.
Men det är mycket one hit wonders därute.
Man kan snarare se röda trådar i vilka element det är som gör att annonsen går bra, vilka uspar vi lyfter och så.
Mer än att nu har vi en kopia på det här.
Jag har en ganska stor kombination av alltifrån en enkel bild som vi har bett tjatje på tid skapa, men med en stark kopi.
Det är något av det viktigaste.
Ibland skriver folk, men du skriver inte produkten, utan säg vad det här gör för kunden och hur det verkligen är unikt att skriva någonting som sticker ut lite grann.
Ditt proteinpulver gör inte det här.
Nu har inte jag använt just det, men som exempel.
Det kanske får folk att haja till.
Sedan har vi en mer storyformat, att man ska inte vara så säljig i annonsen.
Det pratade de förut, men att få skapa igenkänning och en situation och lite mera vem jag som persona och vad är mitt problem som jag tror att många kan känna igen sig i.
Sedan visar jag hur den här produkten gör det för mig.
Det är en mix av 10 sekunders annonser, 10 till 15 sekunder, går ofta jättebra.
Kort och kärnfullt.
Sedan en kombination av lite längre.
Över en minut tycker jag brukar, då kapas videon för ofta också i meta.
Men berätta en story, var lite personlig.
Bryr sig folk fortfarande om det.
Alltså det är såhär, ja man ska berätta en story, berätta, men du, fan, fan, tycker människor det är kul liksom.
Ja, jag är Joel, jag har gymkompaniiet.
Det är ett gäng grabbar ut i en lada liksom.
Är det någon på riktigt?
Vad fan, är det fortfarande så att folk bryr sig om det?
Jag bara tänker att, fan, jag orkar inte bry mig om fler människor.
Jag tycker att jag har en full grupp med människor jag bryr mig om liksom.
Ja, du har det, men inte 55-åriga Christine som har alla barn utflyttade och sitter hemma och skulle vilja köpa en god matchalatte.
Nej men, om vi säger så här, bryr sig folk mer om du laddar, om de en Didio dyker upp på en gymmaskin?
Eller tror du de bryr sig mer om du sitter och pratar om varför du grundade gymkompaniiet?
Ja, de bryr sig säkert mer om det.
Jag bara tycker att det är fascinerande att det är, på något sätt är ju det så simpelt, eller det är en så...
Ja, verkligen.
Kan det inte komma något nytt hack nu som alla bara borde hoppa på och säga aha, nu bryr vi oss om detta istället.
Men det är inte så.
Det funkar fortfarande.
Experimentera rätt och vara personlig utan att vara privat kanske.
Ja, jag har inga nya revolutionerande tips.
Det är det som funkar för oss och det funkar väldigt bra.
Men jag håller helt med dig.
Jag själv sitter och förundras över, vem köper vår produkt efter att ha sett den här annonsen?
Jag kan inte förstå det.
Jag är inte riktigt, jag ska säga överlag, jag tänker inte så mycket som andra.
På ett sätt har det varit en nackdel i mina unga år, medan jag senare insåg att jag har blivit ganska analytisk och systematisera hur värden och sociala interaktioner funkar.
Det var det där som fick dem att göra sådär, då kanske jag ska säga så här istället för sådär.
Jag själv har aldrig köpt någonting på en Facebook-annons.
Något enstaka från ett brand som jag redan känner till.
Jag kan själv inte förstå.
När du går in i ett bolag via straight A's till exempel, har du då en avtickningslista som du går igenom?
Det här är det formatet vi brukar prova igenom.
Vi brukar prova de här olika vinklarna.
Är varje bolag en unik grej och så får man börja analysera vad man tror skulle funka där.
Hur ser den metodiken ut?
Man kan ju dela upp det i vinkeln och vilka uspar vi ska lyfta.
Det kommer att vara väldigt unikt för olika bolag.
Vi jobbar till exempel med ett skovföretag som är en av de enda skovfabrikerna i Sverige.
Att lyfta den uspen och visa att fabriken och hur skorna produceras är en stark usp för dem.
Och hantverket och materialet och så vidare.
Det blir ju unikt för varje bolag.
Eller om du är ett sminkmärke, vad är det som är unikt med just din produkt och ditt smink?
Men sen så finns det ju olika format på annonser, typ att us versus them.
Det kan vi göra för skomärket och sätta upp hur skiljer sig den här läderskon gentemot en annan läderskå.
Eller en founder story, testar vi det.
Eller du borde köpa in till det här som fortfarande faktiskt funkar.
Jag förstår inte riktigt hur men en enkel bildannons med en stark usp eller en lite mer undercover UGC-annons där någon pratar om sitt problem först och sen lyfter.
Alla möjliga sådana typer av annonsformat testar vi och ser vad som kan funka på ett varumärke.
Och det är fördelen och vad jag älskar med att driva byrå, att man får så mycket data och insikter och snabbare kan komma in och bara, okej du brukar testa det här.
Och sen när saker trendar liksom, en sms-konversation kan fortfarande funka eller en screenshot på notes i iPhone.
Att försöka se ut som ett organiskt, en sak som vi testade nyligen som funkat jättebra är, du vet när influencers skriver såhär, Ask me anything.
Jag tänkte säga ja, jag följer någon influencer.
Nej, jag följer faktiskt inte så många heller, men du vet vad det är, exakt.
Och sen så repostar de liksom svaren, frågan och svaret.
En sådan grej bara, en bild som ser ut som en organiskt bild hemifrån, Ask me anything och så typ, ja vad använder du för proteinpulver?
Och så svarar vi på den frågan.
Ja det här det kan jag vara en tryck om.
Varför gör inte folk alla de här testerna, eller vi gör inte detta heller, men liksom är det för att vi är för fega, eller är det för att vi inte har tid, eller är det för att vi inte fattar det, eller är det, vad är det som håller tillbaka alla e-handelsföredrag från att vara bra på marknadsföring?
Jag tror, det är väl väldigt unikt, men om man säger min erfarenhet med kunder jag jobbar med, så de kundsamarbetarna som går bäst, det är där vi får friast tyglar.
Och ibland är kunder lite rädda, men vet man om vi kan testa det så, eller tänk om de missförstår de här, och egentligen är det så.
Vår produkt är ju faktiskt, men då gör vi inte det då, sträcker vi den från listan också, och så blir det med de okra resultat.
Det ena är att jag tycker att det är väldigt mycket, och när ett bolag börjar bli lite lite större, det räcker med att man är fem-tio personer, då är det som att man lite skäms inför varandra, att man ska göra fina annonser och korrekta annonser, men alltså jag är en annons som är felstavad.
Jag skrev istället för konstant slutsåld, så råkade jag skriva kontant slutsåld.
Och min anställda bara, Amanda du har stävat fel här, jag bara, ja för sen går det så bra nu så att jag kommer låta den rulla.
Det är en av våra bästa.
Jag köper det, men jag kan också förstå den rädslan som man känner, när det långsamt börjar bli lite etablerat, så behöver man ändå, du kan ju inte offra vad som helst, för plötsligt har du anställda som du ska tänka på, och du kan inte chansa riktigt lika hårt.
Jag förstår, man vill framstå lite seriöst men det är också skittråkigt.
Så man får stå emot.
Men man får sätta sina guidelines utifrån, nej jag kommer inte låta min anställda köra igång en annons, där det står att vi har fullvärdigt protein för att vårt är komplett avendosera profil.
Vi måste ju vara faktamässigt korrekta, någonstans går ju gränsen.
Men mycket att tycka och tänka, att jag tycker att den där inte ser så bra ut.
Låt meta bestämma istället och bara köra igång den.
Sen vet jag, när man blir större och mer etablerad så är det andra ways of working och jag har jobbat under sådana premisser också.
Men jag älskar den här fasen som vi är i nu, både med Keano och med många av våra kunder där vi är så öppensinnade och förlåtande och kör på.
Känner du att du har någon sorts sista fråga här?
Känner du att du har folks ögon på dig för att jobba ju ändå med detta?
Känner du att du måste leverera nu med Keano?
Nej.
Alltså, jag visste.
Det här låter så kaxigt, men jag visste att det skulle gå bra.
Alla siffror pekade på.
Första veckorna så var jag lite skraj.
Och varje gång som vi får någon liten dip så blir jag så här, oh nej.
Men jag har ju inget, jag driver allt det här med passion.
Vår hemsida ligger nere på straight A's.
Jag försöker inte få nya kunder.
Jag kanske tar mig an något case som jag tycker att det ser väldigt spännande ut, men vi har haft kapacitetsbrist.
Jag tror jag bara tagit in en eller två nya kunder på hela det här året, fast att min inbox är bombarderad konstant.
Förlåt till alla som inte svarat, kan jag få passa på att be mig ursäkter.
Men nej, jag har ingenting att bevisa för någon i natt avseende.
Jag är min egen största kritiker och det är staplarna månad för månad som jag brinner för.
Kommer det här fortsätta vara en bootstrapping-grej eller nu när första bokslutet kommer ut här om det nu blir ett halvår eller ett år såväl, så om någon hör av sig och säger tja vi vill investera i detta kommer du då säga nej?
Nej, jag ser inte...
Bolaget skulle kunna må bra av ett litet tillskott för att hittills har vi inte kunnat växa mer än vad vi har plussat föregående månad så att vi som ökar laga i kapaciteten.
Och det är därför vi inte har gått in i fjäriländer.
Så det finns ju anledning och bolaget skulle kunna må bra av lite mer kapital.
Sen tycker jag att vi löns samma på första åren, fast att vår customer lifetime value är mycket längre.
Så jag tycker aldrig att man ska börja blöda så månad för månad basis, utan med strategiska bets i så fall, i stora lagen inköp.
Jag tar det som ett väldigt tvärsäkert, vi får se.
Nej men jag är ganska öppen för att om någon, och också typ så här med strategiska investeringar och partnerskap och sådär, jag tror inte att ensam är stark och jag är ödmjuk inför att jag älskar den fasen vi är i nu och hur vi driver det.
Jag ville inte ha investeringar direkt från början för att jag visste att jag behöver lägga mitt fulla fokus bara på att få det här att växa.
Nej, på sikt så tror jag absolut att vi kan ta in i alla fall lite pengar.
Amanda, stort tack för att du var med i podden och för att vi fick fråga ut dig lite.
Tack så mycket.
Jag ska inte attta, men jag gör det ändå.
Men Jacob på lagret har inte köpt byxor på nio år.
De är liksom söndriga, det är traser.
Och nu köpte han ett nytt par.
Och det är inte jag som säger åt honom att han inte får köpa byxor, utan det är han någonstans som...